هناك احتمال كبير أن تكون
استجابة اللقاح
قادرة أيضًا على تعطيل هذا الفيروس
لأنه
عليك أن تأخذ في الاعتبار أنه على الرغم
من تغيير تسعة أحماض أمينية في هذا
البروتين ، فإن
99 من البروتين لم يتغير
ونعلم أن
لقاحنا يحفز الاستجابات المناعية ضد
العديد
مناطق هذا البروتين متعددة استجابات الخلايا التائية
ومناطق ربط متعددة للأجسام المضادة
بحيث تكون هناك ثقة
علمية وأن الفيروس لن
يكون قادرًا على الهروب فحسب ، ولكن دعنا ننتظر
التحقق
من الصحة للحصول على البيانات وسنقوم بالطبع
بتحديث بمجرد  لديك البيانات
والمدة التي سيستغرقها هذا
التحقق وهل هناك أي نوع من
أي شيء مبكرًا الآن يمكنك
مشاركته معنا حول كيفية حدوث ذلك ،
لذا سيستغرق الاختبار التجريبي
حوالي أسبوعين لأنه يتعين علينا
توليف هذا المتغير ولكن ما
فعلناه بالفعل هو أننا قيمنا
أه المواقع التي لاحظنا فيها
استجابات تسلا
ضد بروتين سبايك ونحن  ترى
أن
جميع المواقع تقريبًا أه حيث رأينا
استجابات الخلايا التائية لا تزال محفوظة ،
لذا فهذه رسالة جيدة
تعني أن
مكونًا واحدًا على الأقل من الجهاز
المناعي لن
يتأثر أه أم بهذه الطفرات
ولكنك لا تزال  واثق من أن
الحياة يمكن أن تعود بشكل أساسي إلى شكل
من أشكال الحياة الطبيعية ربما في النصف الأخير
منها
ولا يزال تطور هذا الفيروس
محدودًا نسبيًا ، فهي لا تزال مجرد
واحد في المائة من
بروتين السنبلة ويجب ألا
ننسى أنه لا يزال لدينا
الفرصة مطلوبة
لتعديل اللقاح
على هذا الفيروس الجديد تمامًا
إذا لزم الأمر ، لا أعتقد أن هذا
ضروري ولكن
إذا كانت هناك حاجة إليه ، فهناك
إمكانية فنية للقيام بذلك